that's a good Segway wait wait we didn't
you have our email about some guy from
Houston oh yeah just a positive should
we do a positive email I went through a
little depressing rabbit hole
Oh another thing to do that while I'm
looking for this okay card my so my 16
year old niece who's visiting in a month
she's going to like a junior prom and
she's going with this [ __ ] crazy
it's it literally is driving me [ __ ]
every night for three weeks a month
I hear her and her and your his your
niece is my sister
honey honey talk about this [ __ ] prom
drama you know and I'm sitting there
playing stardew valley I can't see it
says hours are there you know I talked
to the principal and she said that you
know if they're gonna have a problem
next year but we don't know but we don't
know what the rest wish again well I
think we should go to um maybe we
shouldn't go lying to me you know II
like every [ __ ] anyway going to catch
fish you know how we always talk about
Filipinos having just the funniest
choices and names like my cousin's name
my sister's name is honey okay oh my god
bad my cousin's name is chick chick
that's okay like Manny Pacquiao's
daughters queen elizabeth's that's
hilarious
that's name and that's that's the one
that's weird I bet you anything that
color Queenie it's a very common name
but then I just find found out today
who's taking my knees Juliana beautiful
name which is real quick what was your
name like a weird name for your daughter
my cactus calendar oh that's good I have
a friend named twinkle twinkle is good
that's good yeah but I want you guys to
hold on we'll see if she
nevermind osmosis osmosis jones there's
awesome ocean there's enough oh [ __ ]
yeah I gotta think of something else
I gotta think of something that's
original here we go um light fixture
like is like it's light fixture going
what I think things could get over here
sink room light fixture get over here
clean your room
succulent yeah that's another one I like
I like single single syllables like desk
or sink lamp lamp II do you guys have to
name one of your children like drywall
drywall drywall is good
just something that's kind of just you
know an object random object that's no
one is called there's no one on earth
that called drywall but would you name
when your children drywall but spell it
differently soil soil that's actually
not soil soil is good so it's good that
you could get away with soil I already
like you if I have a girl I already know
what I want to name her and poppy
doesn't like it what is it cuz it's a
Filipino knee is it it's a me hun no
that's ms-13 chip girlfriend beyond bro
trade with the Philippines and a Meehan
is one of them so it's a Meehan and
Habagat
we're not doing it for Doggett we're
doing Katie yeah we're doing something
really pity Lea or some Samantha
Samantha with
yeah all all nice names but no we gotta
go with something but we need to do
traditional know what is traditional my
name is kalila halala yeah but you're
[ __ ] from your hapu jab jab anyway
we'll think about it if we have one yeah
but sandy is sandy is sandy my opener
Dan tell her baby's coming coming out
I'm so worried wait so are we are we are
are we not gonna have to gun up you know
why Pete you know what you know why
here's why I was convinced guess who had
her baby this weekend who Natasha
Natasha Leggero Oh Pasha had her baby
over the weekend and she had her baby on
her chest and I told sandy I go there's
something about that photo that you can
tell it changed Natasha Natasha had I've
never seen her face like this where it
was content and hi I was waiting for you
like it was such a beautiful [ __ ]
photo I'm about that because I've known
Natasha for so long and Moshe I love
both those got people out there they're
the nicest people in the world and
Natasha used to live in my building in
Silver Lake
oh it's overly yes so I've known Natasha
for so long and just and she's older
how old is Natasha she's in her forties
she is yeah it looks good yeah she's
late 30s early 40s and she had a baby
and it's not I don't think it's [ __ ]
it looked normal well okay but she's
probably she probably has a healthy baby
she probably lived a very healthy life
all I'm saying is if we you and I are
gonna consider it it it has to be in the
neck within the next three years
yeah for sure I don't don't John tonight
I think we'd have a baby I have to have
a baby with you fear with so much
confidence would you be open to
surrogacy what does that mean where your
your child my egg your sperm in planted
into another woman's uterus I've seen
rom-coms like that
Carrie said but it's still our Janice
yeah but then what if the girls like
Aileen Wuornos and she just takes off
with our baby designer if they're okay
if our if our my sperm and your egg
aren't another woman can their genetics
go into it they say no but I think that
there's there has to be something that
bleeds through I would love to watch an
Asian baby come out of a white woman
that's gonna be amazing
what if it comes out like really samuel
l.jackson black well kalila well then I
[ __ ] a black guy goes on my sperm your
support you know my egg and you're in it
just randomly it just came out comes out
just this big black where the race
completely changes but it doesn't have
any of the blood talents that we sat
there is it just looks black but it's
Asian can't run or nothing